it turns out that even Roy Moore's
attorney is some kind of [ __ ]
Roy Moore's of course the Republican
candidate now accused by I believe the
number is up to six or more women of
inappropriate sexual behavior some of
them were underage some were not and his
attorney is this guy named Trent Garmin
who went on MSNBC to try to defend the
totally indefensible and it went bad and
I mean really bad where he started
basically saying that the ethnic
background of the interviewer might make
it so he can't understand why in some of
these situations in Alabama
it was perfectly reasonable for Roy
Moore to ask the permission of the
parents of teen girls for him to date
them as a 30 something year old it is
absolutely bizarre okay and the
interviewers are Ali Velshi and
Stephanie ruhle they are here trying to
figure out what is this about it's
totally normal to have to ask parents
permission and listen to the answer from
Roy Moore's attorney could not be more
bizarre if if Roy Moore doesn't remember
how could he say that it's definitively
false and number two why would he need
permission from any of these girls
mothers or not if they weren't underage
sure that's a good question and
culturally speaking obviously there's
differences looked up Ali's background
there wow that's awesome that you have
got a such a diverse background it's
really cool to read through that but
what is this these cultures you have to
do with dating a fourteen-year-old I'm
not finished with the context of what is
Ali Velshi background have to do with
dating under children fourteen-year-old
girls sure in other in other countries
there's arrangement through parents for
what we would further potential marriage
a lease from Kevin salmon and now Ali's
also spent time in other countries which
are gone too so it's not a bad time I
don't know so straight answer here's the
answer question so he said no comma so
he answered no and then he went on to
say his process would be before he date
anybody whether they're 25 35 or whether
he doesn't know the rate he would ask
the mother's permission so he actually
answered no there's no inconsistency in
that
and I stand by the answer to me it's the
most appropriate proper answer when I
when I equip my wife I tried to put
together an analysis of this
it's unanalyzed Abel right Canadians
can't understand Alabama even in
Massachusetts we have questions about
what goes on in Alabama but it has
nothing to do with anybody's ethnic
background that's for sure Ali Velshi is
from Canada he is an isthmus Muslim of
Gujarati Indian descent so he can't
understand the idea of Alabama parents
giving permission for Roy Moore to date
their kids what is the idea that if Ali
was more familiar with Alabama he'd
understand that 14-year olds are
considered fair game for 30 something
year old lawyers and then I actually
thought a little more about this and it
potentially is quite a bit darker maybe
what Roy Maura's attorney meant is that
since Ali Velshi despite being raised in
Canada he was born in Kenya his father
is of Indian origin his mother is of
South African origin and again he is
Muslim and maybe Roy Moore has this idea
that because of something in a Laval
she's background he should be defending
Roy Moore because asking parents for
permission to date their daughter is not
that different than the arranged
marriages that maybe his lawyer thinks
Ali Velshi was in some way aware of
because of the countries that his
parents are from it's insane right and
and and that's the only heads or tails I
can even try to make out of this and
something is very off with this lawyer
he tried to give Don Lemon a weird
nickname on CNN the other night and it's
it's almost as weird as what I just
played for you take a look at this the
statute of limitations has run out so
there will be no judge and jury
there will be no process that process is
that a woman okay has come forward I
hear you on the record but hey hey Don
Lemon squeeze you keep it easy here's
the thing it's just lemon halves no my
mom didn't name me hold on my mom didn't
name me Don Lemon keep it easy squeazy
it's just on limit go on I got you man
so what I'm saying Don is I got you man
is this how Roy Maura's attorney thinks
he talked to black people you called the
man and
you nicknamed them with things like Don
lemon squeezy keep it easy this is one
of those stories that when I first saw
the headlines floating around I
immediately thought oh this has been
taken drastically out of context it
can't possibly actually be this bad
that's often the case when I see Trump
headlines and then you see the content
you see Trump's tweets or you see Roy
Moore's lawyer and you realize oh no if
anything the headlines are understating
how insane this is
I guess if anything is coherent here is
it's that Roy Moore's lawyer seems to be
as out there as Roy Moore himself and
hopefully after the special election on
December 12th we never hear from either
of these guys ever again discuss this
with us on our subreddit david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program sponsor is live linguae live
lingua is an immersive language learning
platform where you learn from actual
native speakers of the language you want
to learn some of you know that English
is not my first language it's actually
my second language I grew up initially
speaking Spanish because I was born in
Argentina and I now do speak English
I've dabbled in learning French and
Hebrew over the years and when I've made
the biggest strides is when I am
speaking directly to native speakers of
the language and that is exactly how
live lingua works they will match you
with a personal teacher to work
one-on-one they are also a fluent in
English in addition to the language that
you want to learn it's an online
language immersion school you don't have
to sit in traffic going to meet your to
your teacher or tutor you just get on
skype and that's how you connect with
them and have your lesson and it costs a
fraction of what it would cost for a
private tutor david pakman show viewers
and listeners can sign up for a free
trial Skype lesson by visiting live
lingua com slash Pakman you'll hear from
live linguist personal class coordinator
they will contact you arrange a lesson
that works for you with a teacher whose
style also matches your learning style
and then after that time you can decide
based on the evaluation and proposed
curriculum that you will get
personalized to your needs from live
lingua whether you want to contain
go to live lingua calm slash Pakman for
your free trial lesson